the national Transportation safety board
is reviewing another close call at one
of America's busiest airports this one
involved two airliners at Washington's
Reagan National no one was hurt the FAA
is hosting a safety Summit today to
address the string of recent incidents
Chris Van Cleef has more
this latest close call happened last
Tuesday morning between a United
Airlines flight to Chicago and an
American Airlines Regional Jet to
Raleigh at Washington's Reagan National
Airport
reporting takeoff
the FAA says preliminary indications are
the Regional Jet was cleared to move but
may have made a wrong turn crossing the
runway United was about to take off on
yeah just making sure we did have
the DCA incident is the seventh close
call the NTSB is looking into so far
this year they did did not cross the
runway at the time but it came close
board chair Jennifer hamandy does seem
like every couple of weeks you guys are
investigating another close call
is that because you're looking closer at
those incidents there are more serious
ones happening that we believe we need
to investigate as I look at them as a
it's like a fever in a human body and
that it's signaling that something is
not right former NTSB chair and CBS News
Transportation safety analyst Robert
sumwalt will be a moderator at today's
FAA safety Summit bringing together
players from across the nation's
Aviation system to better understand
where the issues may be you do start to
wonder how many close calls does a
system get before an accident
I think these are very much precursor
events that could be signaling that
there's something more serious in the
system the close calls come as Airlines
and the FAA have ramped up hiring and
demand for travel has soared coming out
of the pandemic some of this has to do
with of course post-pandemic effects
Airline Captain Laura einstetler we're
now quickly hiring a lot of new people
into the industry our traffic control
maintenance Pilots everything so it's
taking time to get everyone up to speed
and that's some of what we're seeing
right now
the airlines involved in the incident
here in Washington declined to comment
deferring to investigators safety
experts the FAA and Pilots continue to
stress that flying is safe I think what
you'll hear today is the system needs to
be safer the NTSB investigations they're
looking for any common threads things
like communication issues or loss of
situational awareness perhaps training
issues that may be factoring in the
board has made several recommendations
to avoid these types of situations over
the years that includes technology
that's only been installed at about 40
airports in the U.S Adriana
all right Chris let's hope things
improve thank you